she said yes and then I was like oh okay
great and then I was so overwhelmed and
I kind of collapsed afterwards because I
was so like overwhelmed with because I'd
never been engaged before Rebel Wilson's
fairy tale moment almost turned into a
nightmare I mean I was so excited a week
after she proposed to girlfriend Ramona
agruma the comedian Recaps the big day
on the Drew Barrymore show the full
interview airs March 2nd I was like do I
get down on one knee what do I do and I
was like what did you I may as well so I
got down on one knee and then she like
what you're doing goes well you can't be
the only one on your knees so she got
down as well yes because she he's a
giver not a taker yes so there's like a
happy ending there oh there is a happy
ending as Rebel put in her Instagram
announcement we said yes but afterwards
the picture-perfect moment got a little
blurry and then I was like oh okay great
um and then I was so overwhelmed that
afterwards we went on a ride this new
ride they had and I kind of collapsed
afterwards because I was so like
overwhelmed with because I'd never been
engaged before or proposed to or
proposed so it was like such a huge
thing in my life and then we went on
this new ride I go hang on I just have
to like and I just like literally
collapse on the floor for like five
minutes and then I go okay I'm good
let's get shiros and um
those churros confirmed over on the gram
it's cool we're Rebel documented their
romantic day at the happiest place on
Earth and luckily they put some topiary
trees around us to give us a little bit
of privacy yeah this proposal was
anything but but improvised the house of
mouse even added some pixie dust he also
picked up the phone and called Bob Iger
yes like the president of all of Disney
the Grand Puba like yeah he's the big
the big big boss and I thought well if
he says yes then it was meant to be and
I was meant to propose that day at
Disneyland and because I had to get
special permission to get a special area
roped off you know and a violinist
playing like Disney Classics and it was
very yeah it was really romantic of
course she already had plenty to
celebrate it's amazing it's amazing this
comes after Rebel announced she became a
first-time mom Via surrogate sharing the
news with this pic of her baby girl
Royce Lillian Rebel gushed in the
caption I can't even describe the love I
have for her she's a beautiful Miracle
it's like Love Is in the Air well when
you wish upon a star Rebel Disneyland
the happiest proposal place on Earth
foreign